c'est rami plutôt qu'un discours je
crois qu'il faut poursuivre le dialogue
avec vous conseillers nationaux
nous avons tous écouté les contributions
ce matin cet après-midi et l'engagement
des conseillers nationaux de métropole
d'outre-mer de l'étranger est important
parce que vous êtes tous l'avant garde
des forces vives de l'alternance l'an
prochain je veux féliciter en
particulier isabelle le callennec parce
que nous avons été nombreux à apprécier
isabelle ce matin dans l'animation du
débat où l'intervention des conseillers
nationaux
ça n'était pas une sorte d'exercice
contre un avec l'idée que le plus vite
une question se terminer le mieux c'est
et mais tu a sollicité chacun des
intervenants pour préciser pour
compléter pour proposer et je pense que
cela monsieur le président c'est
véritablement le dialogue et la
démocratie au sein de notre formation
les amis nous le savons la gauche c'est
un désastre mais nous voulons et c'est
le sens de notre travail aujourd'hui
demain nous voulons en 2010 est pour une
fois réussir alors nous sommes écoutés
les uns les autres et j'ai envie de
poursuivre ce que maxime henry danger
disait ce matin en disant il faut
rétablir la confiance la confiance
certains ils répondent avec des réformes
institutionnelles avec aso de
communication
ce que largement fait françois hollande
ce qu'il fait avec ses gouvernements
successifs mais nous le savons pas ce
que nous rencontrons nos concitoyens
nous dialoguons avec nos militants
la confiance c'est d'abord les résultats
la condition nécessaire du
rétablissement de la confiance c'est que
nous ayons nous républicain la culture
du résultat et la culture
le tas exige une première chose c'est
d'être capable de soulever et de faire
sauter un certain nombre de tabous alors
frédéric neveu de charente-maritime à
dialoguer avec nicolas sarkozy et a
évoqué vous avez évoqué ensemble à sion
de questions institutionnelles
j'ai pris une position et je confirme
une position simple modeste mais ce sera
déjà cela concrètement et ça ne sera pas
très compliqué supprimer le conseil
économique social et environnemental
que ce soit sur le plan national que ce
soit dans les régions quand des
institutions coûte et ne servent à rien
il faut avoir la cohérence et le courage
de les supprimer fabienne labrette
ménager notre ami de la sarthe a évoqué
la question de la réforme du statut de
la fonction publique
je crois sur ce terrain qu'il faut être
très audacieux pas même les fonctions
régaliennes justifie le statut de
fonctionnaire d'ailleurs avec quelques
autres collègues nous étions samedi
dernier à la même heure à bord du
charles de gaulle dans le golfe et nos
pilotes
nos techniciens qui entretiennent les
avions et qui porte aujourd'hui
fièrement les armes de la france pour le
plus grand nombre d'entre eux sont des
sous-officiers des hommes du rang d
officier parfois sous contrat et ne sont
pas des fonctionnaires titulaires
alors si les armes de la france c'est
une fonction de souveraineté ô combien
peut être accompli sous contrat c'est en
réalité la grandeur de tout le service
de l'état de s'adapter demain au plus
près des enjeux de notre pays et des
besoins de nos concitoyens c'est le
statut de la fonction publique il faut
supprimer et il faut assumer de le dire
notre ami revanche à prier de mulhouse a
souligné le fatras des aides et nicolas
sarkozy a très bien répondu en disant
qu'il fallait fusionner et une solide
je suis d'accord avec toi nicolas sur ce
point il y à un autre point de la suite
de la discussion sur lequel je ne suis
plus en accord c'est le débat quand la
question du rsa a été abordée
est-ce que les départements aujourd'hui
ont des difficultés la réponse est oui
mais de mon point de vue parce qu'avec
d'autres ici j'ai la conviction et la
culture de la décentralisation
la réponse c'est pas de nationaliser le
rsa la réponse c'est comme le démontre
très bien notre collègue éric straumann
aujourd'hui dans le haut rhin
la réponse c'est une pleine compétence
des collectivités locales ce qu'on
appelle la compétence des compétences
que quand une collectivité locale a une
responsabilité
elle est pas là simplement pour faire le
chèque à la place de l'état c'est ni
mieux ni moins bien mais qu'elle a une
véritable capacité de contrôler comme le
demande aussi laurent wauquiez de dire
quelle est la somme
quels sont les critères quelles sont les
conditions quelles sont les
contreparties
quelles sont les sanctions alors oui
nous devons avoir ce débat pour une
véritable décentralisation
notre ami christiane de vaud de
l'hérault a évoqué le droit de la
nationalité
françois fillon a rappelé tout à l'heure
ce débat assez vain de mon point de vue
sur la déchéance de nationalité vous
mesurez les amis que telle personne qui
demain serait sanctionné de déchéance
pourrait dans certains cas continuer de
recevoir des aides sociales
nos concitoyens ne peuvent comprendre ma
conviction depuis 2010 déjà monsieur le
président si tu l'autorisent c'est que
le sujet en france et je sais que nous
sommes d'avis différents mais le mien et
celui de quelques autres c'est que le
sujet ce n'est pas la condition de
sortie la nationalité c'est la condition
de l'entrée parce que c'est un enjeu
d'identité essentiels eh oui je
l'assument
je suis favorable au droit du sang notre
ami stéphane paoli d'aix en provence a
évoqué cet enjeu important qui est celui
de la transformation numérique
oui notre parti nos idées la droite doit
prendre à bras le corps ce qu'est
l'enjeu de l'économie collaborative
oui il faut alors pour cela une
dynamique une recherche l'innovation et
une autre fiscalité
c'est le sens de ma proposition d'un
impôt universel et proportionnelle
ce que certains appellent la flat tax
parce que c'est plus juste parce que
c'est plus efficace et c'est la
meilleure réponse à une économie moderne
aures les amis supprimant les niches
fiscales c'est un système où l'état vous
dit ce que vous devez faire aimer ton de
la liberté et je propose que chaque
citoyen puisse librement affecter une
part modeste mais une part de son impôt
pour dire la mission qui lui paraît
prioritaire
l'action caritative qui veut privilégier
août à l'initiative d'une collectivité
locale jean charles taugourdeau a raison
et je dis chiche chers collègues
oui la simplification rêver du code du
travail ne se fera jamais la bonne
réponse c'est la véritable liberté dans
l'entreprise et non pas un accord
pouvait repart le code mais une pleine
souveraineté de l'accord d'entreprise
quelques autres tabou dans le domaine du
logement
nous avons eu cette discussion nicolas
le très bon document qui nous a fait
remettre parle de simplifier la loi sru
loi gayssot 1999
non ça ne suffit pas depuis des années
nous demandons son abrogation
et bien quand nous serons au pouvoir
nous nous contenterons pas de simplifier
la loi sru il faut l'abroger
j'ai proposé il ya quelques jours invité
par notre ami benoît crespin cas le
courage d'animer l'opposition dans un
secteur difficile comme gentille avec
les amis d'ivry vitry descoings qui
subissent le communisme souvent depuis
des décennies
j'ai proposé qu'on sorte du concept de
logement social
une règle la situation de personnes qui
enferme nos concitoyens
la majorité des français modestes n'est
pas logé dans le logement social
bien des communes où il ya peu de
logements sociaux ont une vraie mixité
sociale
la seule corrélation nous avons constaté
c'est la corrélation entre le nombre de
logements sociaux et le vote hollande
aux présidentielles
nos français nos concitoyens méritent
mieux que cela
la famille la famille chers amis et bien
je suis de ceux qui considèrent que
quand nous avons été des millions à dire
il ya deux ans trois ans ce qu'est notre
conviction il est important d'y être
fidèle
il est important de l'honorer je ne me
lasserai pas j'ai considéré avec
plusieurs centaines de parlementaires
que la loi taubira était une mauvaise
loi alors ma position n'a pas varié
c'est la mienne en tout cas et je sais
que c'est celle de beaucoup d'autres
la loi taubira je veut l'abroger je veut
l'abroger
je veut l'abroger j'assume
parce que je respecte chacun de nos
concitoyens
la proposition qui avait fait en son
temps nicolas de contrat d'union civile
évidemment on va des mariés personne d
adopter personne mais si l'on veut
demain réussir une politique familiale
généreuse solide stable qui relance
notre pays où aujourd'hui la démographie
baisse et où les familles trinquent et
sont matraqués par la fiscalité
eh bien il faut avoir de la constance et
du courage
d'ici 2017 notre famille les
républicains devra écouter il faut de
l'humilité devra porter un diagnostic il
faut de la lucidité faire des choix
il faut du courage de l'audace et de la
cohérence réalisé garantir la livraison
il faut de la constance alors oui nous
le savons tous aux républicains l'heure
est grave
il sera bientôt trop tard nous le savons
il n'y a pas de baguette magique pour
résoudre les maux de la france c'est
notre oeuvre collective
nicolas c'est celle que doivent porter
tous les conseillers nationaux des
républicains dans notre liberté dans
notre diversité pour assurer le
redressement de notre pays est porté en
le printemps des libertés